[MUSIC PLAYING]
CAMILLE GENNAIO:
Michael Tisserand
is a New Orleans-based
author, whose most recent book
that we're going to talk
about today is called "Krazy."
It's the George Hammerman--
MICHAEL TISSERAND: Herriman.
CAMILLE GENNAIO: "--Herriman:
a Life in Black and White"
is the title of the book.
This book was one of
"The New York Times"
100 most notable books of 2017.
And today, we're going to
learn a lot about Krazy Kat,
about George Herriman, and of
course, about Michael's journey
to get to writing this book.
And Michael's previous books,
"The Kingdom of Zydeco"
and "Sugarcane Academy" are
also well-renowned and amazing
reads.
Over the past
couple of weeks I've
had the chance to learn
quite a bit about Michael,
about George, and
about Krazy Kat
just through some amazing and
very easy YouTube and Google
searching.
So I use our own tools.
And we are thrilled to have him
here today to present to us.
For those of you listening
on the live stream, please--
I'm sure that questions
will come up during the talk
as we learn more about the work.
So please go to
the Krazy Kat Dory.
It's gokrazykat-dory
to add your questions.
We will have a Q&A portion
at the end of the talk.
And with that, I welcome
Michael to the stage.
MICHAEL TISSERAND:
Thank you, Camille.
[APPLAUSE]
CAMILLE GENNAIO: Thank you.
MICHAEL TISSERAND: Thank you.
We're going to be spending
some much needed time
with the funny pages today.
I'm going to be showing
a lot of comics,
including a lot of
comics from the--
some from the late
1800s and early 1900s.
And it's worth noting right now
that the roots of comic strips
and the roots of vaudeville
and minstrel shows
are one and the same.
So some of the comics,
just to let people know,
are going to reflect some of
the ethnic stereotypes that
were on stage at minstrel
shows and on the page
in American newspapers,
and still exist now,
but submerged in
characters, like Cat
in the Hat, and Mickey
Mouse, and Krazy Kat.
So some of them are
unpleasant-- a couple of them
are unpleasant to look at.
We'll talk about those.
And I hope you'll see why
I'm choosing to show them
as part of this presentation
of George Herriman, who I think
is one of our most
amazing artists
that we've been lucky
enough to produce.
And I think speaks so clearly
and wonderful to our time now.
But that's the main course.
And before I get
to the main course,
I want to start with a
little amused-bouche.
So here's a comic from
the prohibition era.
And you'll see why I'm
showing this particular one.
Here's a Krazy Kat comic
strip-- a daily comic.
Three panels from about 100
years ago during prohibition.
There was no need to
explain to the readers
why they were going down
to those private cellars
at the time.
This is Ignatz Mouse.
"Ah-h-h, nobody about.
I'm safe." says Ignatz.
And here comes Krazy
Kat on the next cellar.
"Nobody about.
I'm safe." says Krazy Kat.
And then they close the doors.
And again, remember 100
years ago, there they are.
So there's saying-- and this
is not altered for the audience
here.
This was the comic
100 years ago.
They're down there gulping down
their moonshine with a google,
google, google.
So this might be the first
Google Doodle, I'm thinking.
So that's Krazy Kat
from 100 years ago.
And now we're going to talk
about the birth of the Krazy,
or how this character came to
be-- how George Herriman came
to invent this most
amazing, groundbreaking,
and still, I think,
revolutionary comic strip
character.
So if you were a comics reader
from 1913 to 1944 opening up
a comics page, it might
look something like this.
And if you turned
to Krazy Kat you
might start to read
a daily strip that
goes something like this.
"I just found out
something, Ignatz."
"What?"
says Ignatz the mouse.
"I ain't a Kat."
"No."
"And I ain't Krazy."
"Well, what are you?"
says Ignatz.
"It's what's behind me
that I am," says Krazy.
"And what is behind you
besides your tail, fool?"
says Ignatz.
"It's the idea behind
me, Ignatz, the idea.
And that's what I am."
"Ahh, and that's not
all," says Ignatz.
"There is also a brick
behind you, sipp."
And then the brick collides
with a zip and a peen
on the top of Krazy's head.
So this is a strange
strip for readers
to be turning to in the
1920s, and a lot of them
were confused and
puzzled by it and puzzled
by these characters.
Krazy Kat, Ignatz
Mouse, and there
are a number of
other characters,
but we'll just mostly
talk about Krazy, Ignatz,
and Offissa Pupp.
So first, Ignatz.
Ignatz the Mouse, again,
lived on newspaper pages
from 1913 to 1944, is obsessed
with one thing and one thing
only, and that is
throwing a brick
and striking Krazy Kat on
the skull with it there.
Ignatz is an artist at brick
throwing-- never throws
the same brick twice.
It also sounds very
different sometimes.
This is a very, very early
appearance of the word
jazz in American newspapers.
When Krazy is hit by
the brick, Krazy Kat
interprets it as a sign of love.
Interspecies masochism in
the newspapers in 19-teens,
and '20s, and '30s.
Krazy is convinced that
every brick is a love letter.
And there's Krazy
after the brick toss.
"My dish of romance is full, and
I'm a happy, happy, happy Kat."
And Ignatz stalks away,
"Krazy as a Koot."
The third character
here is Offissa Pupp.
Offissa Pupp is as obsessed with
stopping the brick as Ignatz
is with throwing the brick.
So there's Offissa
Pupp searching around
for the brick in the forest
while a little submarine is
looking for him there.
Offissa Pupp lecturing
Ignatz, "Wasting your time
being evil, wicked, sinful,
and full of skallawagness--
tossing bricks at that dear Kat.
Don't your shame trouble you?
Don't your sin haunt you?"
And there is Offissa
Pupp's stated purpose,
is to have Ignatz in this
beautiful, beautiful panel,
safely in the
Coconino county jail,
with that great George Herriman
potato chip moon up in the sky
there.
But Offissa Pupp has his
own little secret, as well.
Offissa Pupp harbors his
own love for Krazy Kat.
Which we only see once in a
while, such as in this Pupp
fantasy.
And the fourth character
I should mention too
is George Herriman himself.
Here, getting lectured
by Ignatz for having not
drawn a brick yet.
Here, being begged by Krazy Kat
for a bottle of ink with a pen.
Herriman is very much a
presence in his own strip.
So with those characters
from 1913 to 1944,
Krazy Kat appeared in
newspapers around the country,
mostly with King Features and
William Hearst newspapers.
And it garnered a lot of
incredibly notable fans.
T.S. Eliot was a fan.
Langston Hughes
once heard of blues,
and thought it was as
funny as Krazy Kat.
E.B. White said that
Herriman's creation possessed
a bit of the big soul.
And probably the biggest
and most influential
fan was E.E. Cummings, the poet.
And when I read E.E. Cummings'
letters about Krazy Kat,
you can see Cummings'
impersonation of Krazy Kat
on the page--
Cummings' own poetic
voice start to emerge.
And when George Herriman
died in 1944, E.E.
Cummings contacted his
publisher and said--
keep in mind, there was no
way to see these strips.
The papers were all
yellowing and crumbling.
And said, this
comic must not die.
And created the first book
anthology of Krazy Kat comics.
That was seen by a
young man coming home
from military service
named Charles Schulz,
and forever changed the way
Charles Schulz would view
comics, later saying,
"I always thought
if I could do just something
as good as Krazy Kat,
I would be happy."
And there's a drawing from
Charles Schulz, himself,
of Ignatz clobbering
poor Charlie Brown.
Theodor Geisel, or
Dr. Seuss, actually
read Krazy Kat when he
was a child growing up,
and later said, "I'd much rather
spend any evening of any day
rereading the beautiful, insane
sanities of George Herriman's
Krazy Kat, than to sit myself
down at some opera house
to hear some smiling Irish
tenor murdering Pagliacci,"
says Doctor Seuss.
There's a Cat in
the Hat-like drawing
by Herriman of Krazy Kat.
However, despite fans
like this-- and members
the Algonquin Table
were also fans.
And there were
articles about Herriman
being a genius of the comics
page in "Esquire" magazine,
and "Vanity Fair",
and other magazines.
But often, readers would open
up a panel like that "It's
the idea behind me" panel
I showed earlier and not
know what's going on.
And when newspapers would
run popularity polls,
Krazy Kat would more
than likely show up
at the very bottom of
the poll, and often
be dropped by the newspaper.
Often, readers opening
up the funny pages
did not want to
sit and contemplate
on the blissful mysteries of
the soul's sublime passion.
Or encounter a panel like this
in which Krazy Kat goes out
into Coconino county,
which is Herriman's
version of northern Arizona
and Monument Valley area.
"And look with Krazy and
meditate upon every tic
a birth, every tok a
death, and wiza woiza.
Every tic a second, every
tok a million years.
Every tic a nothing,
every toc a something.
And wiza woiza."
So not every reader
wanted to contemplate
being nothing in this time
and eternity when they
are opening up the funny pages.
Or even make their
way through a sentence
like, "If I had widda
to go at, then would I
go widda-- but widda I go
widda, or widda I go not widda.
I still would not know if I went
widda or not-- so why go widda
when one can go wince?"
was not what every
reader wanted to do.
Or come across a
panel that says,
language is so we can
misunderstand each other.
And Herriman presented
these with no explanation.
What's he up to?
Or when Krazy Kat would
walk into a beauty salon,
and walk out again having
changed color completely.
And now Ignatz is for
some reason in love
with the lighter
shade of Krazy Kat.
Again, presented
with no explanation.
Or this daily strip--
Krazy Kat looking at the
mirror, "Not so nice."
"What isn't?"
says Ignatz.
"Golla, why din't you
tell me?" says Krazy Kat,
still looking at the mirror.
"Tell you what?" says Ignatz.
"That I had an inferiority
complexion," says Krazy Kat.
And then the brick comes.
By the way, if you look
at the date on the bottom,
this strip happened to
appear on August 20th, which
is Herriman's birthday.
But what readers really
went crazy about, even more
than that--
and I note, they
complained about it.
There were letters to
newspapers about it,
there were columnists
in newspapers
that complained about it--
is that Krazy was a
non-binary character.
Krazy was both male and female,
or something else entirely.
The pronouns switched
back and forth
feverishly when
dealing with Krazy Kat.
In fact, in my book,
I was very careful not
to use a single pronoun
to describe Krazy,
because Krazy is
neither male nor female.
And that's part of the strip.
Here says Ignatz,
"I notice, Krazy,
that sometimes you are a Miss,
then again, you are a Mr."
"Yes, Ignatz so I am."
Here's Krazy shouting, "Hooray
for the sista hood of man.
Hooray for the fraternity
of woman's kind.
Horray."
And here's a longer comic
that's talked about by a writer
that I really admire
and learned a lot from,
named Gabrielle Bellot,
who is, herself,
mixed race and transgender,
and writes very personally
about Krazy Kat in an
essay for "The New Yorker"
that you can find on my
website, michaeltisserand.com
or you can google her and
find it really quickly.
I think she's a
tremendous writer
and she talks about this strip.
The owl shows up.
[KNOCKING]
"Sir, seeing you here,
I take it the lady
of the house is not in."
"Ah, but she is," says
Krazy and slams the door.
[KNOCKING]
And the owl says, "Lady,
seeing that you're here,
I take it the gentleman
of the house is not home."
And Krazy says, "Oh, but
he is," and slams the door.
"Ah, sly one.
You say the lady
of the house is in
and the gentleman
of the house is in,
then I take it they are both in.
Yes?"
And Krazy says, "No, they
ain't," and slams the door
again.
"So to the winds with
delicacy and slickness,
I'm going to get
rough," says the owl.
"Who is anyway?"
says the owl.
"Who is here?"
And Krazy says, "Me," that
great, simple, liberating
answer, "Me."
So who is Krazy?
Who is this Me?
What is the idea behind Krazy?
In one of these--
again, I'm moving
fairly quickly over it,
but I recommend you go spend a
lot of time with these strips.
Because as you can
see, George Herriman
had an open canvas on the comics
page to do with what he wanted.
It was not a matter
of filling out
four panels or eight panels.
He could create
the story visually
that he wanted to every
time he sat down to work,
such as this story about
the origins of Krazy
Kat in which Joe Stork
on the enchanted mesa
is telling Krazy Kat how Krazy
was dropped into a wash basin
in a haunted house
in the basement.
And Herriman describes the story
of Krazy's origins like this--
that Joe Stork is
telling Krazy Kat a tale
which must never be told,
and yet which everyone knows.
So what is that tale?
Who is Krazy Kat?
And for me, the
answer was trying
to find out more about
who is George Herriman.
So
So when I started working
on this, a couple of things
were known about
George Herriman.
There were photographs of him.
This is George Herriman
as a young man in his 40s,
and then shortly
before he died in 1944.
And this is the one thing that
had been found out about him.
So his nickname was
George The Greek.
And a friend of his said in
the early 1900s, none of us
knew what he was, so we
called him The Greek.
And that became his
nickname, The Greek.
And then in the early 1970s,
this birth certificate
was located from New
Orleans City Hall, which
stated George J. Herriman,
and in parentheses colored,
close parentheses.
This was rejected by some people
who assumed that he was Greek.
It was actually-- they
were very fair to not trust
a document coming out of
New Orleans City Hall.
However, it was also
embraced by many people,
including Ishmael
Reed, the novelist,
who dedicated his
novel "Mumbo Jumbo"
in part to George
Herriman, Afro-American
who created Krazy Kat.
So I set out to try to find
out more about this Herriman
family.
And it took me into Herriman's
neighborhood of Tremé.
And just incidentally, for
those of you who know Tremé
as the David Simon HBO
series, this is John Boutté,
who sings the theme song
to that show, "Treme"
who is a cousin of
George Herriman's.
Here's the church,
St. Augustine,
in Tremé that the Herriman
family worshiped and where
young George Herriman attended
baptisms and conformations.
But what really
surprised me most of all
was to find out how ferociously
political that time was,
and how in the center
of that political time
the Herriman family
were positioned.
This was the center of free
black activism for voting
rights during this time.
Here was a petition
hand-delivered
to Abraham Lincoln by friends
of the Herriman family
demanding voting rights.
And you see in that
third name there--
that's George Herriman's
father who signed it.
Herriman's father
and grandfather
both signed this petition.
Another family
friend had started
the first black owned daily
newspaper in the United States,
"The New Orleans Tribune".
Here is a announcement for
an integrated Masonic lodge
that, again, Herriman's
father and grandfather
were both part of.
The Herriman and Son
Tailor Shop on Royal Street
in the French
Quarter was not only
a place to get fine
fabrics, it was also
a place to get tickets
for political rallies
and demonstrations.
"The New Orleans Tribune"
was located right
around the corner.
One of the efforts made at that
time was to integrate schools.
After some gains were made
during Reconstruction,
during Jim Crow, those gains
were lost in New Orleans.
And it seems to me that that's
why George Herriman's father
gathered up his family
and moved to Los Angeles
when George Herriman
was nine years old.
From that point on,
we see the Herrimans
in every document and every
census report identifying
as white or racially passing.
The Herrimans go to
St. Vincent's College.
There's the first
photograph we have
of George Herriman on a field
trip for St. Vincent's College.
When he's 16 he starts
working at the "Los Angeles
Herald" as an office boy.
And he started to do cartoons,
such as, "The Convention
As The Office Boy Saw It."
Or this panel on
the classified ads
in which he also created
his very first black cat.
At the age of 20 he
ambitiously hopped a train--
we don't know if he
bought a ticket or not--
to Coney Island.
And he lived in a
boarding house who
was owned by a man
named Jones, who
had a shooting gallery
around the back.
And Herriman started beating
the trail for Newspaper Row,
knocking on the door of William
Hearst, for whom he wrote
his first cartoon for the Hearst
newspapers at the age of 21
called, "Maybe You
Don't Believe It,"
where he rewrote
Aesop's fables to give
the fable a happy ending.
Hearst fired him.
He was told he did not have
a spark for cartooning.
And he walked down the street
and met with Joseph Pulitzer,
and started creating more
characters, such as "The Two
Jolly Jackies--
Two Sailors on Perennial Shore
Leave," or Major Ozone's Fresh
Air Crusade.
Again, Herriman was
about 21, 22 when
he created these characters.
Major Ozone does
anything and goes
anywhere to find fresh air.
Bud Smith, the boy who
does tricks-- and you
also see a black cat creeping
around the corner there,
which shows up again and
again in his cartoons.
And then this most amazing,
disturbing, sad, and revelatory
strip that Herriman did
when he was 22 years old
called Musical Mose.
So Mose is a minstrel character
that showed up on stage,
as well as showed up
in newspaper comics.
Herriman created Musical
Mose, a musician.
He did about four
or five strips.
It ran across several
different newspapers,
using, as you see, the visual
cues for a minstrel character.
They're very common in his
newspapers of that time.
They did something with it that
no other cartoonist was doing.
And that's created a story
in which Mose is an artist,
is a musician.
And is an amazing musician.
And Mose goes out and
does an impersonation.
He'll be an Italian one strip,
he'll be a Scotsman one strip,
he'll be an Irish
fiddler one strip.
And he's fantastic
at what he does.
He's a beautiful musician.
The ethnic groups
that he's playing for,
whether Irish or Italian,
they flock to go hear him,
his music is so good.
And then they see him and they
discover that he is passing.
And a panel like this erupts.
"A Scotsman, are you?
How do you like that, Scottie?"
And then you see that bagpipe
that he was making his music
with just in the previous
panel broken now, saying,
"I wish my color would fade."
Really startling work to uncover
from a 22-year-old working
in Hearst in
Pulitzer's newspapers.
The story of racial
passing is really
just starting to be
explored more and more now.
Here's a fairly recent
book that came out
I recommend by Allison
Hobbes, in which she
talks about always
understanding racial passing
as a story of loss.
So loss of self, a loss of
community, a loss of family.
But for an artist,
what could be lost?
This is a newspaper headline
from the "Los Angeles Examiner"
when Herriman is
working on staff
about a doctor who was being
embalmed-- she had passed away.
And I'll read it to you.
The undertaker who
was embalming her
accidentally tore off
her wig with a comb
and disclosed a massive
kinky Ethiopian hair.
Herriman must have known,
he was one headline away.
And seems to have,
besides Musical Mose,
went about doing his work.
And I don't know
what Herriman knew.
I don't know what secrets
his family kept from him.
his family disclosed to him,
or how it might
have been disclosed.
But I do know something
really startling
happened as he was working
back in Los Angeles as a sports
cartoonist.
Every sports page had a
cartoonist, or more than one
cartoonist working on it.
And the biggest story in
sports at the time was boxing.
The biggest sport of
the time is boxing.
And the biggest story in boxing
was the boxing color line,
where John Sullivan
had declared,
I will not fight a black man
in the ring-- never will.
It's beneath the dignity
of the white race
to fight against the color line.
What happened is
African-American boxers
started emerging in the
ring who were superior.
Joe Gans being one of them--
a fantastic lightweight.
He ended up going against Jimmy
Britt in a fight over the color
line and Gans won.
Here's a George Herriman
cartoon shortly after Gans
won in San Francisco.
Here's a detail from it.
Mr. Gans won the fight.
Is that so?
I'll make you take that back.
It's a race riot that George
Herriman's depicting here.
And then in the bottom corner,
"I spose cos I'm black,"
says the little dog.
"Yeah, cos yer black."
says his friend.
Sam Langford, often considered
the finest boxer of the time
battled Fireman Flynn, who kind
of looks like Alec Baldwin,
I just realized this morning.
But he battled Jim
Flynn, or Fireman Flynn
in a boxing match in Los
Angeles that Herriman was there
ringside for.
And now Herriman does
something really incredible,
he starts to depict these
black boxers as cats.
Here's a scene where the
cat is being dragged out
of the Lilywhite Inn.
"Hooray, hooray," the
white boxers are shouting.
And then after Langford
wins his next bout,
he comes back bigger than
ever demanding his entrance
in the Lilywhite Inn.
But the biggest story in
boxing was Jack Johnson,
an idol of Muhammad Ali's,
a intelligent, cultured,
ferocious fighter, a
son of Galveston, Texas.
There's an apocryphal
story of Jack Johnson
that gives an idea maybe of how
people viewed him at the time.
That he was speeding one
time and he was pulled over.
And he asked the officer,
how much is the ticket?
And he said $50.
And he threw him a
$100 bill and said,
I'm coming back the
same way, officer.
That's a little bit
about Jack Johnson.
Also a classical musician.
Jack Johnson had done
something incredible,
he had seized the heavyweight
championship of the world.
Jack London, the
novelist, led the fight
to get Jim Jeffries, the white,
former heavyweight champion
to leave the alfalfa farm
that he'd been tending,
get back into fighting
shape, and reclaim
the heavyweight crown for
the glory of the white race,
stated over and
over and over again.
I published this book
about a year ago.
And I've been talking about
this book now for the past year.
And the parallels to this
time can't escape me.
That in 1910, the divisiveness
and blatant racism of the time
came to a head and people
were forced to take sides.
And there was a boxing match
in which it was all centered
around in July 4th, 1910.
Originally set
for San Francisco,
but there was a death in the
ring a few months earlier,
and they shoved the match out of
San Francisco for Reno, Nevada.
William Hearst sent his best
writers and cartoonists,
including Beanie
Walker and Tad Dorgan,
all of Herriman's
friends to Reno, Nevada
to cover the fight.
Brought George
Herriman to New York.
So George Herriman was
not covering the fight,
he was not ringside,
he was not there
to go to the training camps.
And instead, George Herriman,
now at 30 years old,
did comic after a comic after
comic, specifically exposing,
and lancing, and satirizing
the white hysteria that
had blossomed around
this boxing match,
such as white
pugilists are fighting
[INAUDIBLE] colored battlers.
Distressed indeed
in the dusky fleet.
And you see black boxers
crashed on the color line.
While on the ship, the
white boxers are cheering.
"Bring On The Large Black".
This is Jim Jeffries,
who Herriman often
portrayed as a portly
gentleman, because he was not
yet in fighting weight at all.
"Bring on the large
black," orders Jeffries.
"Gentleman with a large black."
And there the chef is,
"Large black coming up.
Of course not the cup of
coffee that he's hoping for."
One other amazing one.
Again, using a visual style
that's very tough to look at,
but also subverting it and
using it for his own ends.
Here, a child standing.
This is looking at
popular education
and how the fight is
changing everything
about public schools.
Up in the upper
left corner, child
is standing up and declaiming,
"The imaginary line
that divides the earth in
half is not the equator,
it's the color line teacher."
Everyone around the
country had reason
to believe that Jim
Jeffries would win,
because they had
been convinced that
by writers like Jack London,
except for the readers
of the Hearst newspaper.
Tad Dorgan, Herriman's best
friend and a very influential
sportswriter, said
very specifically
that you all don't know
that Jack Johnson is going
to win because you've
been discounting him
because of his color.
And indeed, Jack Johnson
was the superior fighter.
Again and again and again he
showed that in the ring here,
playing with Jim
Jeffries and smiling.
And in fact, Jack
London reported,
the man of the summer
temperament smiled and smiled,
and the day did belong
to Jack Johnson.
While he was fighting, he
was taunting Jeffries--
talking to members of the
press, talking to the refs,
as films were being
shot of the fight.
Now, Jack Johnson
and Jim Jeffries
seem to both know what
the outcome was going
to be because they signed away
their film rights, knowing
that a film of Jack
Johnson's victory
would be next to worthless.
The result-- Jeffries is
knocked out over the canvas
under the blazing Nevada sun.
And the immediate result across
the country were race riots.
New Orleans,
California, New York.
Tenements were set fire
where blacks were living,
blacks were shot and killed
for celebrating too loudly
on the streets.
Oddly enough, William
Hearst newspapers,
which had been stoking with
bloodlust-- the battle again
and again and again, now took a
new turn on its editorial page.
"The Prize Fight Was
Disgraceful, Demoralizing,
and Harmful.
And in the name of decency,"
the Hearst papers extorted,
"the fight films
must be destroyed."
And there's Uncle Sam.
This is not a Herriman
cartoon, by the way.
This is a ponderous cartoon
by Robert Carter, clearly done
by Hearst's demand.
"In the name of
decency, Uncle Sam
is destroying the fight films."
But here comes George Herriman
with his own idea about what
to do about these fight films.
In "Moving Picture Owners
Have Their Troubles, Eh?"
by George Herriman.
He has a man walking up and down
the aisles of the movie theater
in a plaid suit shouting,
"Here you are, get
your transformation glasses.
They make the whites black
and the blacks white.
You can't see the
show without them."
And two weeks after the
fight came this comic.
Underneath "Mr. Dingbat
Demands His Rights
From The Family Upstairs," which
was a story about the Dingbat
family that Herriman, a
cartoon dareman, is doing.
He added these two characters
in the bottom, Ignatz Mouse,
Krazy Kat-- not yet named.
Ignatz creeps up
slowly and slowly,
takes up something, maybe
a little brick or a pebble,
throws it Krazy's head.
And Krazy looks back and
wonders what happened.
And Krazy Kat was born.
That was the start of Krazy Kat.
Underneath-- in that gutter
space of the Dingbat family.
And it had become his
own strip in 1913.
And it's certainly
hard to reduce
Krazy Kat to any one idea,
despite what Krazy told Ignatz.
But you do see again and again,
something really interesting
happening with notions of
identity, language, and color.
If you remember that early diner
scene of Jim Jeffries ordering
the cup of large black,
here you see Ignatz saying,
"A cup of coffee black."
Krazy's now in the
kitchen, "Here."
"This isn't black
coffee," says Ignatz.
"Sure it is," said Krazy
"look under the milk."
Or this scene.
"Gosh!
What a kinky tail," says
Ignatz looking at Krazy.
"Kinky my elbow," says Krazy,
"I just had it marcelled."
So this idea of curly hair
being represented by the tail
reflected the fact
that George Herriman
was known by family
members, by friends
for always wearing
a hat to cover
his own head, both
indoors and out.
Here, Herriman did
a comic about it.
"Look, he's got his hat off,"
says Krazy, "Yeah, and look
what he found in it".
If you remember
that beauty parlor
that Krazy Kat once went
into to change colors.
Herriman explained
that in a later strip.
"Dark cats go blonde,
blonde mice go dark.
It's all wrong."
"It's style."
"But it upsets all the
processes of law and order."
"It's style."
Very late in his
life, George Herriman
created a new character called
The Brown Weasel, or Mr. W.
Weasel.
And the insurance company
considers him poor risk
when he's brown.
This is about a
year before Herriman
died in 1943, this comic.
"Fancy a color making a
difference in its value,"
said Krazy Kat.
"Is this the place?" coming
back to that same beauty parlor.
"Yes, this is the
place," said Ignatz.
Then the weasel
comes out pale white.
"Wonderful, a blonde beauty,
pale moonshine, white hibiscus,
fair flower,
snowflake." says Ignatz.
"I'm a bleached weasel,"
says the weasel.
So this idea of beauty, again,
ideas that Herriman could not
speak out loud.
Herriman was married
to a white woman.
He lived in property that had a
racial covenant attached to it.
He would lose his
property if it was
known that he was
African-American or mixed race
at the time.
So this idea of beauty that he
interrogated in the comic strip
is an incredible thing
to see looking back.
But also I want to talk about
what George Herriman also
found in his life, which
was a new way of looking
at beauty itself.
And for George Herriman,
he found this in Arizona--
he found this in Monument
Valley, Arizona specifically.
Here are The Mittens if
any of you have been there.
He would go there every
summer he could for as long
as he could, staying with
a family, the [INAUDIBLE]
in Kayenta, Arizona.
Krazy Kat was set
in Coconino county--
his own version of
Coconino county.
And in fact, the landscape would
shift behind the characters
while they were talking.
There might be a butte one time,
a mesa, a cactus the next time,
always madly dancing as
if they were on stage
and there was a drunk
stagehand moving the scenery
back and forth while the
characters were talking.
And Herriman, in one of
the few serious interviews
he gave about Krazy
Kat said, people
don't talk enough
about the scenery,
but to me that's as important as
any character I've ever drawn.
We might know Monument Valley
from John Ford's movies,
like this one, "Stagecoach",
showing the West
as a place where you
go prove yourself,
and maybe a man goes
to prove his manhood.
But Herriman got there first.
Here is Krazy Kat napping
in Monument Valley,
looking for "sweet silence
in which to slumba,
but them silly mittens
break out with applause."
Herriman was
fascinated by the Diné,
or Navajo and Hopi Indians.
And spent time going into
a hogan, eating lamb stew.
I was able to find a few
individuals in northern Arizona
that knew him from this time.
And ideas and customs from
Navajo life and Navajo
art, such as weaving
would show up in Krazy Kat
as well during this time.
He did the most amazing thing.
He was living in
Hollywood at this time.
And as a way to give back,
there was a tuberculosis asylum
in Kayenta, Arizona.
And he would send
westerns every week,
they were shown at the
hospital in Kayenta.
And it was the social event
of the time for both whites
and the Diné and Hopi Indians,
would all show up and watch
this together.
And some of the letters
and memories of this time
include this very strange
memory that the white folks
had that the Indians
who were in attendance
would laugh at the
strangest times.
They ended up finding
out that some locals were
used as extras, and they
would talk among themselves.
It was captured on
the film saying,
look at this idiot here pointing
to the white hero in the movie.
So in appreciation
for his work, this rug
was woven and given to
George Herriman as a gift.
But it was a Navajo
beauty prayer
that shows up again and
again in Herriman's comic.
And here, as opposed
to the beauty parlor,
as opposed to the
cultural norm of beauty
that he was critiquing a
bit, lampooning, satirizing,
having fun with, and
including in Krazy Kat,
this other idea of beauty
also shows up again and again.
The Navajo beauty
prayer, which a woman
that I was able to talk with
who knew George Herriman--
Betty Rodgers-- said they
recited every morning
as children, "With
beauty before me, I walk.
With beauty behind me, I walk.
With beauty all
around me, I walk.
My world walks in beauty."
This prayer shows up again
and again in Krazy Kat.
Offissa Pupp, "A good Earth a
gracious globe lies in beauty."
"Shifting sands dust its
cheeks in powdered beauty."
Here's Krazy Kat,
"Before me beauty is.
Behind me all is also beauty."
And I guess it's that that I've
gotten personally from my 10
years with Krazy Kat.
Living in a time
now that I would
posit as divisive or worse and
as prone to violence or worse
than the 1910
Jeffries/Johnson prizefight.
Knowing that Herriman
created this little miracle
of comic art
creation, a character
that inhabited that world and
found Krazy's way to beauty
is, I think, a little
miracle of art.
And I'm going to close
here with just a few lines
that Herriman wrote
to his critics.
You have written truth,
you friends of the shadows,
yet be not harsh with Krazy.
He is but a shadow
himself, caught
in the web of this mortal stain.
We call him Kat.
We call him Krazy.
Yet he is neither.
At some time will he ride away
to you, people of the twilight.
His password will be the echoes
of the vesper bell, his coach
a zephyr from the west.
Forgive him, for you
will understand him
no better than we who linger
on this side of the pale".
So that's the birth of the Krazy
and a little bit of the story
of George Herriman.
Thank you, all.
Thank you to Black
Googler Network.
And I encourage you to
spend much, much, much, more
time with Krazy Kat.
It's a strip that continues
to surprise me and teach me
every time I open up a page.
Thank you very much.
CAMILLE GENNAIO:
Your book starts
with such a deep
history of the family.
MICHAEL TISSERAND: It does.
CAMILLE GENNAIO: Is that
part of the reason--
because I feel like his
story is so incomplete.
There's been many books
written about the work.
And I think that your book
goes deeper into the family.
Is that why you did
so much research--
MICHAEL TISSERAND: I know
more about the Herrimans
than I know about my own family.
[LAUGHTER]
CAMILLE GENNAIO: Wow.
MICHAEL TISSERAND:
And I think it
was really important to
figure out not just the DNA,
I guess, but also
the ideas that we're
moving the Herrimans through
19th century New Orleans.
So Stephen Herriman, the
white riverboat captain,
George Herriman's
great grandfather
and Justine Olivier,
the free woman of color.
There was a huge free people of
color population in New Orleans
before the Civil War.
And that's one reason
why it was the center
of black political
activism during that time.
I think that when we
saw Herriman erupt
with those comics during the
Jack Johnson/Jim Jeffries
fight, when we saw him go to
something like Musical Mose,
go to those kinds of
really interesting stories
that you don't see anywhere
else in the comic page in quite
that way--
it seems that the noisiness
of that family around those
issues during that
time, the unwillingness
to accept New Orleans
culture as it was
and to try to move it
forward during that time,
that that was
submerged in Herriman
and came out during those times.
That is my interpretation.
Herriman doesn't write
about this, and in the book
I really tried hard
not to say what
I thought Herriman was thinking
at a certain period of time.
But it does seem that just
looking at the work itself,
that it reflects the agitation
of the 19th century in New
Orleans, as well as the
agitation that Krazy Kat lived
in the 20th century.
CAMILLE GENNAIO: Right.
And if there's any question in
the audience, just interrupt.
MICHAEL TISSERAND: And
it's just so amazing.
CAMILLE GENNAIO: It is amazing.
MICHAEL TISSERAND: Fascinating.
There was a Creole
seance movement
that Herriman's father
and grandfather went to.
And they would gather in
a room a couple of blocks
away from their
home, and they would
engage in automatic writing,
in which the spirits of Jesus
Christ or Benjamin Franklin
would talk to them and say,
there's a better world coming.
Keep working, the
light is there.
Don't rest.
It's just that combination
of trippy spirituality
and political activism.
It's like 1960s New Orleans--
1960s United States in
a certain kind of way.
It's just an incredible thing
to witness and read about.
CAMILLE GENNAIO: I'd say that
in my small amount of research,
I also see the parallels
to a lot of things
that are happening here now in
2017, 2018 as you were writing.
What kind of impact do
you feel that this work--
as people continue to explore
Krazy Kat, George Herriman,
some of his earlier works--
could have on us now,
even in such a--
we have so much access now.
We have Google, we have YouTube.
We can research everything.
You have access
to everything that
happens almost immediately.
How can use this kind of
historical information
to help better ourselves
and better our lives?
MICHAEL TISSERAND: It's
funny, we have access,
and then there's
still a lot of stories
that we don't have access to.
The Library of Congress set
out this wonderful Chronicling
America series, in which
they were going to digitize
American newspapers.
And they ran out of funding.
None of the Hearst
newspapers are up there.
And none of the
Hearst newspapers
are on the private sites, like
Ancestry or Genealogy Bank,
or newspapers.com.
So I actually had
to spend the better
part of about a year and a half
just spooling through pages
and pages and pages of microfilm
to get to some of the stories,
to find out that
they made jokes--
his friends in the newspapers
where Herriman was working
were making jokes about
his hair in print,
to find out that there were
headlines about racial passing
in the newspapers at that time.
But the comics were there.
You're right.
Krazy Kat comics are there.
Interestingly
enough, too, I think
we're having a
renaissance of comic art,
in part because of the web.
I think web comics opened
up a whole new world.
That blank canvas
that I talked about,
where that Krazy Kat origin
story was played out on,
that would not have been
possible-- that was possible
in the teens and '20s,
and somewhat in the '30s
when Herriman was drawing.
But by the '50s and '60s
and '70s, the reason why
Charles Schulz' Peanuts
worked the way it did,
is because Charles
Schulz worked in a way
that the panels could be
shrunk down and still read.
That amount of detail
was just no longer
possible in the comics page.
And that's still the
case in print newspapers.
But on the web, of course,
it's wide open again.
And Herriman's work
was also incredibly
personal in a way that
the comics at that time--
maybe "Happy Hooligan,"
or "Katzenjammer Kids,"
or "The Yellow Kid," they were
sociological and political
sometimes, but not so personal.
Herriman did a
comic of Krazy Kat
seeing a falling star
land on the desert floor,
and realizing it's a baby star.
And Krazy was sleeping
and took the pillow out
of the pillowcase, and held
the pillowcase over the fire,
made a hot air balloon, and sent
the star back up to the heavens
again.
And then a note came down and
said, I'm back home, thank you.
And in looking at the
date of that comic,
I realized he did that comic
right after his daughter died.
He did really
personal work that I
think points the way
to memoir comics,
like Allison Bechdel's "Fun
Home" and Art Spiegelman's
"Maus," and the new boom time
we have of graphic novels.
If you go to the comics shelf
of your local independent
bookstore there's just an
amazing amount of work that
some acknowledge
Herriman and some don't.
But I think they do all come
from his idea of creating
allegorical, yet
very personal work.
CAMILLE GENNAIO: Any questions?
Yes, [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: So thank you again for
taking us through this journey
from this person I had
never even heard of
and now I feel like if
I were to meet him today
we will have a
lot to talk about.
MICHAEL TISSERAND: I
feel that way, too.
I had one dream about Herriman.
And I dreamed that
I was told Herriman,
"I think I found your birthday."
And he said, "You
think so, huh?"
So I can't imagine what talking
to Herriman would be like,
but I think it would
be very elliptical.
AUDIENCE: That's really fun.
So I can't help
but wonder though,
what was your personal
motivation in this journey?
I assume you've probably been
a comic your whole life--
I mean, into comics
most of your life.
And then how did you go from
being into comics in general
and then getting
interested to this person
and following his work?
MICHAEL TISSERAND:
Yeah, I did love comics.
As a kid, I was
obsessed with Peanuts.
Actually, I drew Charlie
Brown constantly.
My mom would drop me
off at the Willard
Library in Evansville, Indiana.
And I discovered on my own
the 741.59 section, that's
where all the comics were.
So you'd see "Katzenjammer
Kids" or "Dick Tracy."
This is late 1960s, early 1970s.
There was no Quentin
Tarantino for me,
but there was Dick
Tracy, which is
a weird and violent and bloody
as any-- it was like nothing
else.
It was not like the
"Hardy Boys" or--
AUDIENCE: There was no Marvel?
MICHAEL TISSERAND:
Well, there were.
I couldn't get to them though.
I wasn't allowed to buy
comic books, actually.
I disobeyed and bought
Wacky Packies, but--
AUDIENCE: There wasn't quite
the universe of Marvel--
MICHAEL TISSERAND: Right,
not the way there is now.
But there was "Spiderman"
and "Fantastic Four."
But I really started
to approach it--
I was editor of the
"Gambit" newspaper,
the weekly newspaper-- the
alt weekly in New Orleans.
And I knew the story of
Herriman's birth certificate
being found, and I knew that
it was still controversial
and nobody really
knew Herriman's story
in New Orleans.
So I approached it with
that in mind at first.
And just started to research.
And then Katrina hit.
The newspaper was
back up and running--
my wife lost her job and
we were up in Chicago
for a couple of
years after Katrina.
And at that point,
I switched to doing
a lot of Katrina reporting
and writing about the effort
to rebuild New Orleans.
And right at that time,
an exhibit of original art
came through the country.
And it only went to Los Angeles,
Milwaukee, and New York.
So I went to
Milwaukee to see it,
and the second room was all
George Herriman originals.
And I have a really
visceral memory.
I was carrying my son, who's
6' 6" now, but at the time
I was carrying him.
He was young and I was reading
Krazy Kat aloud to him.
And I went into a
little bit of a talk.
But Krazy's hard to read, and
if you skip over it quickly,
you're not going to
really dive into it.
But if you read it out loud--
just like any poetry--
if you read it out loud,
it will start to emerge in
a different way for you.
And I was reading these panels
to Miles and making the voices,
and Miles was laughing.
And I just knew right then
I wanted to know everything,
I wanted to learn
everything I could
about the person who created
that comic, who I knew also
was exiled.
In a very different time, under
very different circumstances,
also exiled from New Orleans.
So a very personal moment.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you so much, yeah.
CAMILLE GENNAIO: Does anybody
else have any other questions?
I'd like to say that I think
that the idea of passing, which
like you said, is being explored
more and more and more now.
I actually am from a family,
where we discovered sometime
in the '90s that we also had--
my great-grandfather who
disappeared and actually went
north.
And we found family
members who thought
that their great-grandfather
was a white man,
and had figured out
since that he was not.
And we eventually reconnected.
So I know this is a story
that many families, especially
in the south and the southeast
of the United States share.
But that struggle-- and
you mentioned in your talk
that even at nine,
how much was he really
aware of as he was growing up?
Not that you could know,
because like you said,
it's not like you had
the opportunity to speak.
MICHAEL TISSERAND: He
never spoke about it,
never wrote about it.
Never wrote in any letters
at least that have survived.
We just have Krazy Kat to read.
CAMILLE GENNAIO: Right.
So he never discussed
it specifically?
MICHAEL TISSERAND:
Not that I know of.
His granddaughter has been
a huge help on this project
to me.
And she, like everybody
else, found out
about the story
in the early 1970s
when his birth
certificate was found.
She was actually
living in Africa
at that time with her
husband, who is a professor,
and was thrilled to learn--
it just made her family
that much more interesting.
And I think it made
the work makes sense
to her in a new kind of way.
But as far as Herriman
himself, really all we can read
is what's in Krazy Kat.
And there's so much.
I did highlight some of the
material about identity,
and language, and race, as that
prohibition cartoon showed you.
There's also just some cartoons
that are just very funny,
and don't hinge on
those kind of themes.
It's a 30-year--
31-year comic.
So there's a lot of work there.
But an amazing
amount of humor does
settle on some of those
questions about language
not really working to describe
identity, about the idea
that even terms like
black and white--
as we know, one drop meant
black as a polluted kind of way.
Bliss Broyard's book,
"One Drop," by the way,
I'd also really recommend.
Her father, Anatole Broyard
was a "New York Times"
literary critic, and had a death
that confession to his kids,
oh, by the way, there's a reason
why some of the family members
you've never met.
So her book is a memoir
and explored that
in a very, very personal way.
And her family and
the Herriman family
were in the same community
in New Orleans at that time.
But we don't have anything
like that from Herriman.
I can only extrapolate from
other historical sources.
CAMILLE GENNAIO: There's
a lot in the work.
MICHAEL TISSERAND:
There's a lot.
CAMILLE GENNAIO: It seems to be.
MICHAEL TISSERAND:
And I think now,
racial passing is seen
as a moment in history.
I think we have hopefully--
I really don't take anything
for granted as far as how
we're progressing these days,
but it seems as if we're moving
toward a time of greater
inclusively of allowing
different kinds of
narratives about identity,
accepting the multiculturalism
that we all live in, respecting
the strains of community and
family and beliefs that weave
together, and realizing,
like you said--
especially when people send
out for their DNA test and get
surprises--
that the lines aren't drawn
the way we think they're drawn.
CAMILLE GENNAIO: Right.
MICHAEL TISSERAND:
When I grew up,
there was no racial passing.
There was sexual preference--
sexual orientation.
Not preference-- sexual
orientation passing.
And there were gay
people in my school
that could not be
openly who they were.
So I think about that.
I can't really
identify with Herriman,
who's from a different time.
But I think we all know people
who can't be who they are.
And some of us know people that
that was devastating to them.
And I can only
imagine what Herriman
went through there
and his decision
to create some of
the kind of work
that he did, so full
of love and joy.
And it's so much
pointing toward beauty,
it fills me with an
incredible amount of joy
and hope also
during these times.
He's been a pretty good
companion in this last year
in American history for me.
It's been a subject I've been
very happy to talk about.
CAMILLE GENNAIO: Well, we are
thrilled that you came here
to share with us today.
And I did just write down--
like, deep appreciation
for beauty was the last note
I took from your speech.
Because I've been
looking at the comics,
but you're right, that I
wasn't looking at the scenery.
MICHAEL TISSERAND: Yeah.
CAMILLE GENNAIO: So you
have to look at everything.
MICHAEL TISSERAND: Yeah, these
wonderful, doodle characters--
no pun intended--
these really simple--
Ignatz Mouse, just a few
lines and a line for the tail.
But behind, you have this
cross-hatched shadows
and it's multi-dimensional.
And they're just
simply gorgeous.
So yeah, it does exist on
so many different planes.
CAMILLE GENNAIO: Wonderful.
Thank you so much.
MICHAEL TISSERAND:
Thank you very much.
CAMILLE GENNAIO: Thank
you for showing us
what might be the official
first Google Doodle.
MICHAEL TISSERAND: Exactly.
CAMILLE GENNAIO: I'm going
to send that to the team
and see what [INAUDIBLE].
MICHAEL TISSERAND: Please do.
Herriman's birthday
is August 20th,
so that would be a
good time perhaps.
And I encourage
everybody, of course,
to visit your local
independent bookstore
and purchase "Krazy", as well
as any of my other books.
And my website,
michaeltisserand.com,
has a lot more
comics and stories
and writing about Krazy Kat.
CAMILLE GENNAIO: Great.
Thank you so much.
MICHAEL TISSERAND: Thank you.
Great to meet you.
Thank you Black Googler Network.
[APPLAUSE]